this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben well today marks columbus day or it
has as it has newly been touted by now
the biden administration and by many
major cities around the country
indigenous people's day and it's worth
examining in a little bit of detail how
columbus day has morphed into indigenous
people's day because this really i think
may have been the first step in the
united states
toward the dissolution of sort of
national monuments what i mean by that
is that there are monuments that had
been argued over for a long time because
they honestly ought to be super
controversial so for example confederate
monuments you understand exactly why
people would look at that and go why
exactly is their statue of a person who
rebelled against the united states you
get that you understand that and
certainly you see from a black american
perspective why you would look at a
confederate statue and say to yourself
well that person literally has a statue
for fighting for the enslavement of my
ancestors right the confederate statue
is not a statue to
uphold the glory of the united states
it's a statue about people who are
legally speaking traitors
and you understand the countervailing
argument which is that
we have to actually recognize the
ugliness of our history in order for us
to move forward and tearing down those
statues
is a mistake that obliterating history
in any of its forms is generally a
mistake that's the position of conolisa
rice okay and then on the other end of
the spectrum statues that should not be
torn down you have statues of george
washington which over the last few years
have been hit with red paint you've seen
statues of george washington torn down
you've seen actual american heroes being
obliterated
and the idea there is that virtually all
american heroes participated in crimes
and injustices of their time meaning
they were very common at the time and so
most americans look at those people and
they say okay what were their historic
contributions to the united states
versus what were their demerits of the
time not meaning if there were a person
who did what george washington did today
what would we do to that person that
person would go to jail slavery is
illegal for example but in the context
of the time when slavery was near
universal across
virtually all of the world what did he
do that was good what was different
about george washington that was what
was the same as his compatriots okay
well when you look at christopher
columbus which has now become sort of a
hot topic when you look at christopher
columbus which is he closer to george
washington or a confederate monument
is he closer to a person who did
something truly kind of amazing and
heroic but participated in the evils
that were very common to his time or is
he someone who's predominantly
characterized by his evils
so for most of american history the
answer was pretty obviously the former
and christopher columbus did something
unbelievably heroic right he did more
than any of us have done he got on a
boat he crossed a giant ocean that had
not been mapped and he proceeded to find
hispaniola on behalf of the west right
he found cuba on behalf of he landed in
the bahamas on behalf of the west
and this was considered a pretty damned
brave thing he had to go to multiple
different countries in order to find
funding for his voyage he had to somehow
withstand mutinous sailors who who got
about three quarters of the way there
and they're like we are in the middle of
nowhere would you like to turn around
now
and that to to
kind of shortchange what columbus did
is
not only a historic mistake but reveals
a certain level of historical ignorance
because it's kind of an incredible feat
just on the face of it and you don't
have to deny any of columbus's sins or
the sins of the people of the time in
order to recognize the historicity of
the feat the historic importance of the
feat because the fact is that opening
the north american continent to the west
has paved the way for the united states
which of course is why we celebrate
columbus day right benjamin harrison was
the president of the united states when
columbus day was declared an official
federal holiday in 1992 and he wrote a
proclamation encouraging americans to
mark the 400th anniversary of columbus's
voyage he said on that day let the
people so far as possible cease from
toil and vote themselves to such
exercises as may best express honor to
the discoverer and their appreciation of
the great achievements of the four
completed centuries of american life
right it was the discovery that was
being celebrated not columbus's
treatment of the natives the discovery
now the reason again this is important
is because when we look at history we
have to look at what made the person
different not what made the person the
same as all the other people who are
doing evil things at the time okay so
over the past couple of decades
particularly there has been the rise of
something called indigenous people's day
which is a celebration of the people who
are here before columbus now i have no
problem with a day celebrating the
culture and achievements of people who
are here before columbus but to put it
on columbus day is very specifically
political in fact if you wanted to have
an indigenous people's day and you
wanted to have it coincide with for
example an american holiday the better
holiday to do that would probably be
thanksgiving considering that
thanksgiving is a day when native
american peoples actually helped the new
european settlers on the continent i
mean this is why when you were growing
up the way that this was celebrated
thanksgiving in school is some of the
kids would dress up as squanto and some
of the kids would dress up as pilgrims
and they'd all have lunch together
and if you want to celebrate the
contributions of indigenous peoples
typically you don't do that
on the day that is dedicated to the
discovery of the americas by the west
right if you want to have an indigenous
people the only reason to have
indigenous people's day on columbus day
is to specifically hone in on the
supposedly unique evils of christopher
columbus or of the west discovering the
americas
in sort of the same way that you will
see the
you'll see the arab population in israel
commemorate quote-unquote nakba day on
the foundation of the state of israel
right the idea being that the state of
israel was the destruction that the
state of israel is the bad thing it's a
disaster right this is what indigenous
people it's it's a zero-sum game when
you decide to place indigenous people's
day on the same day's columbus day it
doesn't have to be a zero-sum game you
could have columbus day celebrating
columbus and then you could have
indigenous people's day celebrating
indigenous peoples they don't have to
occupy the same day but there is a
reason they occupy the same day and the
reason they occupied the same day is
because of an attempt to twist american
history into a long procession a long
procession of abuses and evils
unending even until today
the case for indigenous peoples day on
the same day as columbus is basically
the 1619 project you're just calling it
the 1492 project the idea being that
american history is just a long train of
abuses it began in 1492 and it has not
ended today
i would say a lot of the roots of
indigenous people's day lie in the
historian howard's in for those of us
who are following the debate over
critical race theory and the teaching of
history in the schools the truth is that
critical race theory being taught in the
schools is sort of the second wave of
radicalism being taught in the schools
the sort of howard zinn version of
american history where america is
indubitably bad top to bottom howard
zinsman was pushing that back in the
1970s and on
and that's had a pretty market impact
because now indigenous people's day is
being celebrated from the white house to
pretend that there is no ideology
attached to this is to ignore the actual
history of indigenous people's day if
you look at history.com for example
they talk about the fact that the
original controversy over columbus day
was actually nativist okay because there
were a lot of people in the united
states who didn't like catholics and
they thought that honoring columbus was
honoring catholics okay but says
history.com in recent decades native
americans and other groups have
protested the celebration of an event
that resulted in the colonization of the
americas the beginnings of the
transatlantic slave trade and the deaths
of millions from murder and disease okay
so number one to pretend that
colonization between tribes didn't exist
before the west got here or that the
slave trade didn't exist before the west
got here and there wasn't an official
transatlantic slave trade obviously
there was certainly a ringing and robust
trade of slaves or at least slavery
happening enslavement of of captives
happening routinely across the the
americas before the west ever got here
the deaths of millions from murder and
disease right this is what they say
millions of people died from murder and
disease in the americas long before
christopher columbus ever set foot on
hispaniola
right it's it's being treated as a
zero-sum game so for the white house to
sort of embrace the zero-sum game is
indicative of just how deeply rooted
this ideology is and i want to get
deeper into what the ideology means in a
second here's jen saki saying that it's
very important to this white house to
commemorate indigenous peoples day not
as sort of a generalized thank you to
native americans for their contributions
to the united states and also for their
contributions to world history but
instead to do it directly on columbus
day
well today is both columbus day as of
now and this is why you're asking the
question as well as indigenous
people's day i'm not aware of any
discussion of ending that uh either of
ending the prior federal holiday at this
point
but i know that uh recognizing today as
indigenous people's day is something
that the president felt uh strongly
about personally is happy to be the
first president to celebrate um and to
make it um
the the
the history of moving forward
okay so why exactly are we tying these
two things together okay the answer
obviously is that the upside for the
west is the downside for everybody else
and this is the this is the general
howard zinn take on american history so
howard zinn was a professor at boston
university he wrote a very bad book
called the people's history of the
united states it is cribbed from a bunch
of other sources frankly and it's filled
with a lot of pseudo-history zinn was a
communist and so a lot of his or at
least a communist fellow traveler and so
much of his writing is rooted in an
almost soviet view of american history
as just completely evil top to bottom
dominated by capitalist rapaciousness
in in this view i mean howardson talks
openly about this the idea was that
european dispossession of native
americans is the root of property rights
right the property rights are bad that
was the problem that underlying the
evils perpetuated by columbus against
native americans were property rights
and property rights are inherently bad
because again howardzin was a communist
fellow traveler a traveler so howard's
in i mean i write about this in my not
the latest book but the one right before
how to destroy america in three easy
steps i write about this they say howard
zinn opens his masterwork by contrasting
the arawaks of the bahamas islands who
he says were quote very much like
indians on the mainland who were
remarkable european observers were to
say again and again for their
hospitality their belief in sharing with
the evil europeans who were dominated as
it was by the religion of popes the
government of kings the frenzy for money
that marked western civilization and its
first messenger to the americas
christopher columbus right so that's the
contrast the contrast is the sort of
russoian noble savage notion that
everybody who is living in the americas
before the west got here was wonderful
and it was kind of pocahontas and the
disney movie and then the west got here
and it was all rape and capitalism
in this narrative columbus was merely
western brutality writ small the natives
by contrast were quote the ideal of
humanity quote columbus and his
successors were not coming into an empty
wilderness but into a world where human
relations were more egalitarian than in
europe and where the relations among men
women and children and nature were more
beautifully worked out than perhaps any
place in the world right this is what
howard's in writes
now
begin with this even if that were true
the even if it were true that everything
was wonderful in the new world and then
columbus came here and this was somehow
a representation of the evils of
property rights what that would
demonstrate is not the evils of
capitalism it would demonstrate the the
evils of seizing land from people which
is actually not capitalism
but the more important argument which is
which is zin's argument that america was
sort of born in sin and is thus
irredeemable
unless you just get rid of property
rights is is really silly okay the
reality of course is that you don't have
to minimize the brutality of european
treatment of native americans to
recognize that the russoian vision of
what america was before the west got
here is just not true
harvard stephen pinkler pinker says
quote contra leftist anthropologists who
celebrate the noble savage quantitative
body counts such as the proportion of
prehistoric skeletons with axe marks and
embedded arrowheads or the proportion of
men in a contemporary foraging tribe who
die at the hands of other men suggest
that pre-state societies were far more
violent than our own
but that of course is the entire goal
the idea is the west is uniquely bad and
everything was before in order to
contrast what happened before the west
is uniquely good
now that of course is not true human
evils tend to be pretty common to pretty
much all the humans
and again the the basic notion that
everything was sort of hunky-dory on the
continent before the the west got here
is is also not true i mean there was
vast enslavement of of other warriors by
tribes there was not by the the native
americans that columbus dealt with but
there was apparently uh a a tribe that
had been
engaging in in cannibalism that was sort
of nearby and had been actually praying
on the taino according to according to
the most recent sort of scientific
estimate
the notion here is not to justify
anything that columbus did that was bad
against native americans the point here
is that all of human history is replete
with evil when we pay tribute to people
what we are paying tribute to is the
good that they did not the evil that
they did and to pose those two things in
direct contrast as though what you have
to do is choose between columbus day and
indigenous peoples day by putting them
on the same day as though they are the
flip sides of one another or as though
indigenous people's contribution ended
when columbus got here is also very
silly
you can pay tribute to columbus and then
if you want to pay tribute to indigenous
peoples you can do that on a different
day it doesn't have to be the same day
the reason that it was done on the same
day is because again the idea was that
what was good for the west was bad for
everyone else because the west is
inherently kind of bad
and that is untrue
but but that idea has led to some pretty
bad law actually
like it's kind of fascinating
there is something called the indian
child welfare act that is still on the
books in the united states and it
actually harms native american children
but again it's predicated on the idea
that we have to
treat people in different ways based on
race which is which is a mistake
which was in fact the mistake of
columbus as it turns out now removing
history from from its context is one way
of uniquely condemning a civilization
and that is a huge enormous mistake and
when it comes to doing good for native
americans today we do a lot in this
country that is rooted in sort of
symbolic attempts to appease native
americans for example and it doesn't do
anything for actual native americans on
the ground so for example we had a big
debate over the washington redskins and
removing the name and calling it the
washington football team and all this or
the cleveland indians changing the name
of the team
right the idea is that that is
inherently insulting which again i find
kind of bizarre because if you ever
called the team the cleveland jews and
they went around beating up the new
orleans saints i'd be like wow that's
kind of great but in any case
the the idea is that we have to the the
best way to pay tribute to particular
racial groups in the country
is to
is to worry about their sensitivities as
opposed to making their lives better and
the reality is that if you wanted to
make lives better for native americans
living in the united states today you'd
worry a lot less about columbus day and
quote-unquote indigenous people's day
and you'd worry a lot more about the
state of play in native american
reservations which are
disproportionately suffering from
poverty and joblessness
and we've constructed laws that make it
worse for those people there's a really
interesting article in the or in the
orange county register by a guy named
timothy sandofer
who's vice president for litigation at
the goldwater institute and he talks
about something called the indian child
welfare act
he says more than a dozen states have
recently chosen to recognize the second
monday in october not as columbus day
but as indigenous people's day in an
effort to acknowledge the nation's
indebtedness to native americans as well
as the many injustices they've
experienced over the centuries it's
fitting that the supreme court is now
poised to consider a case involving one
of the greatest injustices ever
inflicted on native americans the case
involves a federal law called the indian
child welfare act icwa which effectively
bar states from protecting native
american children from abuse and denies
them opportunities to find permanent
caring adoptive homes enacted in 1978
with the goal of preventing state child
welfare agencies from taking children
away from native american parents on
insufficient grounds icwa went too far
in the other direction
icwa categorizes children as indian
based exclusively on biological ancestry
even kids who are not tribal members
speak no tribal language and have never
lived on a reservation qualify because
they are quote unquote eligible for
membership because of blood ties
then the act imposes a separate set of
rules whenever state courts review cases
involving their safety and those rules
are way less protective than those
applied to other kids for example if a
white or black kid is abused by a parent
the state can take her into protective
custody as long as it first makes quote
reasonable efforts to preserve the
family unit this is not required if
aggravated circumstances exist like
molestation or drug addiction but the
icwa requires active effort a term the
law doesn't define but which is more
demanding than reasonable efforts and
this is not excused by aggravated
circumstances this means state agencies
must return indian children to families
they know are hurting them the results
are often tragic montana officials knew
anthony renova was being abused so they
placed him in foster care for four of
his five years of life had he been
non-indian he might have been adopted
instead thanks to icwa the state was
forced to return him to abusive parents
in february 2019 and nine months later
they beat him to death
the icwa requires that indian children
be adopted by indian families instead of
families of other races because there
are not a lot of indian families looking
to adopt native kids in need are often
bounced from foster home to foster home
never finding a permanent home you
remember that there was a pretty famous
case recently in which there was a
foster home where the foster parents
wanted to adopt a native american kid
native american kid had never met his
native american relatives the courts
refused to allow the foster parents who
had known the kid for years to adopt the
kid because of the icwa
in other words very often the policies
that people on the left think are going
to help native americans very often
actually hurt native americans
but the goal is symbolic here i
understand that the reason that we've
transferred over from columbus state to
indigenous peoples day is not really
about helping native americans it's
about the symbolic notion that the west
is inherently bad and that the sins that
the west participated in which were
participated in by virtually all
civilizations of the time including
civilizations that
were present on the north american
continent when columbus got here
the idea is that columbus's mere arrival
was the worst of all the things
right that he had somehow changed the
nature of the game in terms of in terms
of disease or murderousness or all of
the rest
this is why you get all the claims that
are made in schools now colleges that
christopher columbus perpetuated a
genocide that is not true a disease
kills lots of people
the german theory of disease was
certainly not
in knowledge in 1492.
and as it turns out there was disease
that had been killing native americans a
lot longer than that because disease is
a universal to the human experience
and the point of all of this is is again
not to downplay the contribution of
native americans whose contributions
particularly in the northeast of the
country at the foundation of the united
states can be seen in some of the
documents even of the time
nor does this downplay native american
culture is to point out that when you
treat history as a zero-sum game what
you end up doing is placing modern
people who live today in direct
opposition to one another and you end up
undermining the roots of a civilization
that has provided great prosperity for
enormous numbers of people including
native americans on the continent of the
united states living today right that
does not mean the justice the injustices
of the past are excused it does mean if
you're going to look at history and
context you have to actually be
responsible about it you can't pretend
that only the bad exists or that
the the good that was done by columbus
arriving on the continent is outweighed
by a bad that was universal to the time
if you do that there will be no statues
of anybody left in history because as it
turns out
pretty much every hero that we have
anywhere throughout history has
committed sins that were universal to
the time in 200 years all the people we
consider heroes today will be considered
villains for a wide variety of new
reasons that will have cropped up over
the
next couple of hundred years every
single person who we're building a
statue to today will be that'll be torn
down in 100 years if this is the logic
that you hold to these again human
beings are complex we have our upsides
and we have our downsides and it's very
important to recognize our contributions
not just the villainy that was universal
to the time and that then had victims
attached to it
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
destroys like button with clicks and
logic i'd watch that make it happen gang